we've done a lot of stuff on dieting and
health on the show we talked a lot about
aspartame but sugar maybe Mike Bloomberg
was right a new study in the journal of
american medical association jama has
said that sugar is doing more damage to
our bodies than we originally thought
added sugars according to most experts
are far more harmful to our bodies than
naturally occurring sugars this is when
you put a spoonful of sugar and
something as opposed to eating an orange
ursine like that the US government
hasn't issued a dietary limit for added
sugars like it has four calories fat
sodium etc that's why when you have a
coke and it has however much sugar in it
it's literally like 20 spoonfuls and
they're allowed to do that and sugar is
classified by the FDA as generally safe
which allows manufacturers to add
unlimited amounts of any food so it's
interesting because America we sort of
got off sugar a couple years ago and
everybody was doing the diet soda thing
and then the last two years diet soda
has disappeared because of all the
chemicals is this just obvious stuff
that we should all know that you should
not what I'm saying adding sugar yeah
one can of soda is twice or three times
as much as the sugar you should one can
of giada is twice a three much yeah
three times as much as I mean like that
literally like 20 spoonfuls of sugar
let's not forget it's high fructose corn
syrup which I know we've talked about a
thousand times which is why the FDA also
is not coming out against it the way
they do for fats and other things
because we put this corn syrup in so
many different things yes murs are so
involved in using corn instead of using
regular sugar that if the FDA were
suddenly come out and say look sugar is
bad for you which it is which is pretty
much been proven in every single way and
you'd have a panic and farmers would
lose money and the corn industry is
highly subsidized by its usually
subsidize yeah do you have a problem
there with both like the government
saying that we supported by subsidizing
it than the same time if they say that
it's bad for you you'll have a mass
panic in this country no one would you
do themselves but server makes you sick
makes you fat it makes people of
headaches it makes you tired I mean who
doesn't know this by now yeah so what is
the alternative to this because our are
you a sugar if you were if you had a
coke and a diet coke in front what do
you I'm a non soda guy not so tough that
said you know as far as people that are
smoking the things drinking alcohol that
soda is probably the worst thing you can
do for your body so as I said before it
is
Bloomberg right I lived in New York City
at the time during the the ban he wanted
the big ban and he was even pushing it
literally as he was being pushed out of
Gracie Mansion but was he right
Bloomberg was absolutely wrong by making
a sugar bad because we live in the
United States of America and in America
people should be free to choose I think
the biggest problems that people don't
take personal responsibility for
themselves so everyone wants the FDA to
ban something or the government to say
something's not good for you look we
need to be presented with the
information so the FDA should be giving
us clear information about what their
studies have found and maybe help us
with some guidelines but it's not up to
individual cities or people to ban
things that aren't of immediate eminent
danger instead give us the info and let
people decide right so I'm on board that
museum the donation can I don't want to
see it that is not what we're doing at
the creations but I'm on board that idea
that we should have the freedom to do
whatever we want if you want to buy a
big-ass o at 7-eleven you should be
allowed to but isn't there partly an
issue there that people are just sort of
dumb not only people are kind of dumb
but they don't want to know what the
truth is and they're uneducated how
would they even get the information
teach you something in grade school
about what the FDA are sweet they told
us that yours and they're never kind of
that kind of evaporates from our now
right so that lasts till what about
fifth grade media and then must be
Darwinian at this point I'm so over it
at this point I might look if people
want to drink soda and be fat and be
unhappy be lazy and be depressed and
then men self medicate themselves with
all the pharmaceutical drugs take care
of all the problems they've caused by
eating think food that isn't good and
not exercise god bless you you know I
mean I'm serious I think it really is
personal responsibility and I do think
there is a little bit of trouble with
access to the information and that's the
problem because when you have a lot of
corporations kind of with vested
interest in the media when you have
lobbyists that are able to kind of get
in the pockets of politicians the access
to information isn't as fair so this is
kind of not the point of this whole
sugar thing but if you get the money out
of politics kind of make sure that our
media in some way it least has to stay
who they're owned and sponsored by not
stop saying anything let the meat is say
what they want but make things a little
bit more transparent we'll have more
informed people think people are
starting to be a little bit more aware
especially with the internet over net
neutrality went out the window
I think I did it there you go we're
talking about sugar you gave me net
neutrality money out of politics but
that's the thing there's no simple
answer to all this and the reason why
after talking about it for a few minutes
I actually pass out of bang my head
against a totally as I know I can get me
a diet coke is that there's just there's
no way to talk about this without
talking at all the different factors
that contribute into it you can't have a
conversation with issue over bad for you
and should we drink it without knowing
everything surrounded by the sugar
culture in this country and why you know
continues yeah